STEPHANIE WONG: This
week, we're talking
about better business
analytics, data warehousing,
and translation AI.
Welcome to "This Week in
Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Google and Looker
are joining forces
to push cloud-based business
analytics even further.
This means the addition
of several new features
to Google Cloud Platform,
including the power
to define metrics once
and then apply them
across data sets,
built-in applications
for industry-specific use cases,
and data visualization tools.
Read more about what the
acquisition of Looker
means for GCP customers
on the Cloud blog.
Then, try it out.
But our roster
doesn't end there.
We're also bringing Snowflake,
a leading cloud-based data
warehouse provider, into
the fold, in this case,
through our partnership.
Customers who already use
Snowflake for powerful data
insights can now get seamless
access to GCP's AI tools
and, of course, our newly
reinforced data analytics
capabilities.
See what a
partner-first strategy
looks like in practice on GCP.
We at Google have been dealing
with translation for a while.
So we're excited to announce
v3 of our Translation API.
Listening to our customers,
we added new features
like choosing between
pre-trained and custom
models, batched translations,
and more granular control
over specific words and phrases.
Enjoy a smarter version of
the same powerful Translation
API without upgrading anything.
Our treat.
Knowing how to secure your
Kubernetes environment
is pretty important.
The good news-- it's
never been easier
to learn how, thanks to our
self-paced lesson series
on Qwiklabs.
Whether you're running
Kubernetes yourself
using our Google Kubernetes
Engine manage service
or using Anthos,
complete this quest
to learn the ins and outs
of migration, monitoring,
and security.
Get started.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment, or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.